this is the toughest test on television
I'm telling you 10 weeks every week you
get through one week and the whole
process starts again learn a new dance
and everything that goes with it it is
grueling physically and mentally what a
fabulous way to start this off
you know who am I I'm just a dance
teacher from Dartford suddenly I'm
thrust into Hollywood
I think part of the charm of the three
judges is that we all come from slightly
different sort of backgrounds so you
sort of get different critiques and
sometimes things I say upset them
sometimes things they say upset me but
you get a proper critique of the whole
performance I'm from the Baldwin world
so I judge everything on ballroom and
Latin Standards and you know if they go
too far away from that I don't like it
this is a ballroom dancing competition I
want to see true ballroom dancing and
when I see all bizarre happenings oh I
don't like it four five four
because what I see is what I say overall
it was a mess the England it was more
like a hoedown than a touch of child
okay oh I didn't mess it up go hear me
messed it up sound like all that shaking
the trouble is it is such an intense
competition that there isn't the time to
learn the routine and then to polish and
master those little extra bits if you
dare lose focus then you are dead in the
water that's what you see sometimes in
the rehearsal rooms you know crying and
arguments because frustration set in and
the further you go through the series
the further and harder all these
tensions become it's a bit like moving
with golf I miss a three foot Pat and I
can't forget it for five five holes
later I'm still thinking how did I miss
that three footer
I think the fact that it's live gives it
that age there's no well let's do it
again stop and start again if there's a
mistake there's a mistake and it's there
for everyone to see and that gives that
edge to it that Dynamic that is a thrill
it's like a road crash you know when a
road crash happens the other side
everyone slows down to see what's
happening
I've met my heroes I got to do the twist
with Chubby Checker and it was so moving
to see Sugar Ray Leonard and Buzz Aldrin
come out and give it a go what I like
about Dancing with the Stars we've had a
woman with one leg we've had someone
deaf we've had an 82 year old woman and
they've all come out and performed
really well and what I love this shows
anyone can dance doesn't matter anyone
can dance and what I hope is that people
watch the show and they think I'd like
to have a go at that and it gets people
into a ballroom exercising and dancing
and learning about the joys of having a
dance I
absolutely loved it yes
good man
foreign